et si avec ça votre enfant rue chine
toujours à étudier l'histoire de france
et ses châteaux mais je vous propose une
autre ruse le château de cheverny dans
le loir et cher qui raconte l'histoire
d'un héros de bande dessinée si je vous
dis moulinsart vous aurez bien sûr
deviné qu'il s'agit de tintin reportage
frédéric bonnet et daniel lévy comme si
l'imagination de millions de lecteurs à
travers le monde ne suffisait pas comme
si tintin ne pouvait pas se contenter
d'être un reporter imaginaire il faut
encore qu'on nous raconte des histoires
cette histoire de tintin à cheverny
c'est complètement inventé
pourquoi y est je n'en suis pas sûr
pour que le rêve bascule dans la réalité
il faut des preuves alors la direction
de cheverny a épluché l'oeuvre d'hergé
le capitaine haddock aurait-il trébuché
dans l'escalier de cheverny
le mystère reste entier mais la vraie
question est de savoir si hergé lui-même
est venu ici tintin aurait donc
réellement vécu dans ses murs non j'y
crois pas pourquoi je suis pas juge j'ai
mes doutes existentiels ne serait pas la
maison de tintin ici oui mais pas dans
paris
pourquoi parce que je pense que t'as pas
n'existe pas des millions de francs ont
pourtant été investis à côté du château
pour nous faire croire à cette histoire
pour une exposition dont le but n'est
pas mercantile
non c'est pas une opération marketing
maintenant je m'inscris en faux bond
comme on dit c'est pas du tout menacé
c'est une c'est une opération
patrimoniale artistiques culturelles et
si ça doit améliorer la rentabilité de
domaine bien entendu c'est une bonne
chose
un lieu où étais tu viens vite on va
commencer en perçant les secret de la
licorne tintin ne savez peut-être pas
que son habitation avait été édifié par
louis xii et qu'elle attirait un jour
350 mille visiteurs par an
je n'ai peut-être pas tout à fait
traîner les jeunes et la règle
le faut régler le son ils sont en
réalité que cheverny soit moulinsart ou
inversement ce n'est pas très important
l'essentiel est de continuer à croire
que le rêve peut un jour devenir réalité
une exposition permanente au château de
cheverny dans le loir et cher